what's going on guys this is rob and
i've been thinking about this for a
little while not a fully fleshed out
plan mind you it's really more of a
spark notes kind of thing right just
kind of an early glossing over of this
idea but the dc eu
is in a rough spot and this is not going
to be one of those videos where like i
rag on the dc cinematic universe right
dc extending unit whatever they want to
call it you know expanding universe i
don't know it's not really one of those
honestly they get dumped on all the time
the reality here though is that man they
got problems dude between amber heard
and ezra miller you know kidnapping some
kid and being on the lam it's just one
of those things where it's like they
just really can't seem to catch a break
and the reality is that it just kind of
seems to fall on top of this idea that
like their entire movie landscape is
just in shambles no one has any idea
what in the world is going on because i
think in reality warner brothers has no
idea what's going on i think that what
you're looking at here when it comes to
the dc cinematic universe is you are
looking at a situation where you have a
series of movies
created by a company in a board room as
opposed to the the marvel cinematic
universe where you have at least in the
early days right the first 10 years
those guys who don't know a lot of those
movies were crafted by comic book
writers right so you literally had an
inner circle you had brian michael
bendis you had joe casada you had kevin
feige who was a comic book fan joss
whedon was a comic book writer before he
was a comic book director he wrote
astonishing x-men one of the best x-men
runs ever written this guy you know
these this group assembled a lot of
these movies because it was comic book
experts making movies about comic book
characters the dc cinematic universe
doesn't really feel like it has that and
so what i've done here is i'm kind of
breaking things down a little bit and
again this is by no means like a
definitive plan it's more of just kind
of ideas and stuff like that the reality
is that first things first they need a
reboot i know they're doing joker 2 and
different things like that and in
reality it kind of feels like they're
focusing less on a cohesive cinematic
universe and more on just a series of
movies that features future characters
and there's no doubting the fact that in
some ways that works with the joker for
example that's not tied into anything
it's just a movie that's a more
realistic depiction of how the joker
could exist in the real world as opposed
to the comic book depiction where he
falls into a vat of chemicals and comes
out going crazy that kind of a thing and
the movie did exceedingly well and it
was incredibly well done so there's no
doubting that kind of stuff when you
look at the batman by robert pattinson
right that was a pretty solid batman
movie is it the best batman movie i've
ever seen no but it was a great batman
film i absolutely loved it there was no
point where i was really bored and in a
lot of ways the fan base really seemed
to be supportive of it the problem with
this is that these things are just out
there and there's no cohesiveness there
and right wrong or otherwise the reality
is that when you're talking about a
comic book film landscape now
it isn't really the age of just making
comic book movies that exist out there
and they may or may not tie into each
other and it's whatever that was the
early 2000s with like x-men and
fantastic four and spider-man and all
that stuff right just movies that were
there right blade back in the 1990s what
people want now is a cohesive universe
they want to feel like they're kind of
on this big journey with regards to
these characters that are going on their
own individual adventures but also
reconciling back into a larger hole and
so in a lot of ways i think that dc just
needs to wipe the slate clean and say
hey we had some great movies let's take
the stuff we learned from those movies
flashpoint all of it and then just wipe
it clean right just be done and it's
just like a whole new series of events
or they just basically start over right
just rebrand and rename because one of
the cool things to remember is that by
and large people don't really care about
what movies you made they care about
what movies you're making it's the
reason why people laud the success of
the the marvel cinematic universe and
they ignore things like howard the duck
or that that terrible fantastic horror
movie from the 1990s i know a lot of you
guys probably don't remember that there
was a fantastic four movie back in the
90s one of the ending scenes is reed
richards waving goodbye to everybody
with his hand sticking up through the
moon roof of a car and it's awful that's
on top of everything else about that
movie that was terrible
but all that gets swept under the rug
because people are focusing on what's
going on now so
the reason why i say that is to say it's
not too late right it's not a lost cause
kind of thing so first thing we do here
is we jump into a batman film and i know
a lot of people are kind of like really
batman yes really batman and the reason
why is because it's batman arguably he's
more popular than superman you'd have to
leave the planet earth to find people
who don't know who batman or superman
are and even then you may not pull it
off right there's probably aliens out
there somewhere that are watching the
old christopher reeves superman movies
and the old tim burton michael keaton
batman movies so
[Laughter]
the kicker about this is you can do it
in a couple different ways one of the
things that i think they should do is a
combination of different stories which
is usually what happens when it comes to
comic book movies very rarely do comic
book movies ever focus on a singular
story arc and then bring that to life in
an actual film for example infinity war
in avengers inn game that's a
combination of thanos quest the original
thanos story when he showed up on earth
searching for the cosmic cube and fought
marvel as well as jonathan hickman's
affini uh infinity during jonathan's
avengers new avengers god you know uh in
addition to obviously the infinity
gauntlet story there's like four or five
different stories that were borrowed
from to create that film so with batman
we do the same thing right this is clean
slating we're done you know honestly i
wouldn't even bring back bad flick i
would not bring back anybody who's
played batman before if for no other
reason than to avoid confusion among the
viewer base right the the people who are
watching the films and don't really know
about comic book history different
things like that just to avoid that
confusion i wouldn't bring back anybody
else also there's the marketing side
right i mean warner brothers is a
multi-national billion dollar company
it'd be pretty easy for them to market
this as them just rebooting the entire
movie landscape and just starting from
scratch so what we do here is we borrow
from a couple different stories the
first one that we borrow from is batman
war on crime and the second one we
borrow from is the court of owls now the
third one we would kind of touch on a
little bit in the beginning which would
largely be like zero year by scott
snyder or batman year one by frank
miller you don't necessarily have to
it's the origin of batman we don't even
really need to see it anymore i mean
literally bruce wayne's a kid his
parents got shot in an alley and then he
became batman done batman's origin
explained in five seconds right we don't
need that whole thing we know how that
story goes now the reason why i chose
these stories is because batman war on
crime is in my mind one of the single
greatest batman stories to ever
encapsulate the nature of the character
it was written by pauldini it was drawn
by alex ross beautiful artwork right
alex ross is one of the greatest comic
book artists of all time what this did
is it told the story of a kid whose
history in a lot of ways mirrors bruce
wayne where his parents are basically
killed in a crime and he was kind of
left to himself the result of this is
that instead of him having the resources
of bruce wayne the billions of dollars
of the wayne family this younger black
kid actually just ended up falling into
a life of crime because there weren't
really any other opportunities for him
and one of the most most beautiful
moments in the entirety of the story is
at the end when batman's just kind of
trailing this kid's life right sort of
following this kid keeping an eye on him
that kind of a thing not extremely
closely but relatively closely and you
end up having this moment where he
basically shows up at a warehouse where
there's a burglary taking place and sees
that that kid is one of the people who
were there committing the crime and when
the kid turns around he pulls a gun on
batman and batman's just kind of like
wow right i mean this this is how easy
it is for just the average person to
fall down into a life of crime because
they don't have my resources and so in
this really really touching moment like
batman tells this kid guns are what took
both of our parents don't let guns be
the thing that destroys you and like
this kid starts crying and like batman
whole diminishes it shows you a side of
bruce wayne that you never see you know
whenever you see batman you always see
him beating the hell out of people now
it has to have that kind of tone i
wouldn't necessarily say the movie needs
to have that storyline it would be cool
if it did and i think that'd be a great
kind of concept to have in it because it
would show a more tender side of batman
as opposed to the guy who's just beating
the crap out of people all the time but
the overall story that we're telling
here right what we're really focusing on
is the court of owls and the reason why
is because the court of owls is largely
considered to be the single greatest
batman story told in the modern era
there are better batman stories out
there but a lot of them are origins so
some of those are like the dark knight
returns which is bruce wayne and kind of
a dystopian future there is batman year
one by frank miller really the
definitive batman origin story there's a
lot of different stories out there that
are better than court of owls the reason
why i choose the court of owls though is
because you can build the idea behind
the court of owls is it told us this
story where you essentially had a group
operating in the city of gotham that
batman didn't know about i mean he knew
the idea behind it there was always this
kind of rhyme that went out there right
beware the court of owls that watches
all the time and that kind of a thing
but it was kind of like this inner group
that existed there and there was even
this kind of indication of the comics
that the court of owls were actually the
ones behind the death of thomas and
martha wayne now that turned out to not
necessarily be the case but it showed
this idea that despite all of his
vaunted capabilities and batman claiming
to know gotham city as well as he does
that he actually doesn't that in some
ways he kind of got carried away with
himself that when he was a kid he heard
the story of the court of owls and he
tracked down the court of owls or tried
to believing they were the ones
responsible for the death of his parents
but every lead took him to a dead end so
ultimately he believed the court of owls
just didn't exist only for us to find
out that they did and they were wildly
influential and in fact it actually
turned out they were an international
organization which just places all you
know little groups all over the place
now that's where i think the court of
owl started to kind of fail but within
the confines of this story the reason
why this would be cool is because yes it
would give us batman beating people up
but the more important thing here is it
would take it away from just some
mindless batman movie where he's
pummeling criminals and would give us a
kind of really just a really good
detective story not only that in the
court of owls there's a point where
batman gets caught and he's taken to a
place called the labyrinth and there's a
legitimate belief that he might die
there he actually starts to go insane in
that place before he finally manages to
find a way to escape but it's one of
those great stories that i think would
would trans really transform into a
phenomenal batman movie because by using
these two stories it gives us the side
of bruce wayne that we don't normally
see that he's just not hard on every
single person who commits a crime
everywhere that he also recognizes that
his place how he got to where he was
being able to even be batman is really
more of a luxury and that there are
people out there that just don't have
that same kind of access and just do
whatever it is that they can to make it
in the world the best they can using
whatever it is they happen to know at
the time now following that we would go
into a superman movie right now again
superman we don't need the origin of his
character i mean we can kind of get it
but we don't need to see krypton explode
we don't just see his parents sending
him off on a ship and he ultimately
lands on earth and if we do get that we
get that in the way that we got the
origin of the incredible hulk in the
edward norton movie right it happens
over the course of the opening credits
it's the origin of superman we all know
the origin of superman we don't need
that so what we would do is we would
borrow from a couple different stories
again we would borrow from pauldini and
alex ross regarding peace on earth and
then we would borrow from superman
birthright and the reason why is because
superman birthright is the definitive
superman origin story but the movie man
of steel was not terrible it was a zack
snyder movie right so a mini michael bay
film i think it was a little more a
little too much mindless action and you
could definitely see the differences
between christopher nolan and and zack
snyder right christopher nolan's
influence was very heavy on that film in
the slower more methodical parts that
focused on superman himself as opposed
to zack snyder which was just like
explosions or explosions by michael bay
and zack snyder for those of you guys
who ever watch robot chicken what this
movie would do is i wouldn't necessarily
say it would be a deconstruction of
superman but it would be a movie that
would bring superman down to our level
but also show us how much higher above
us he actually is so the idea behind
peace on earth again written by pauldini
and alex ross is it's basically superman
coming to this realization that there
are tons of people out there in the
world who struggle and so what he does
is he actually brings together this idea
of trying to help other countries right
bringing them food and grain resources
different things like that like
literally trying to feed the world and
what he runs into along the way is
basically political blockades there's
one point really towards the end of the
story when some of the resources he has
are actually shot down are destroyed by
a government out there in the world that
wants to ensure that its people stay in
a state of like starvation or or
destitution and squalor because it means
they'll be heavily dependent on the
government we're not really given a
definitive answer as to what that
government is but it's largely alluded
to being like north korea or russia or
something like that but just some
corrupt group that exists out there but
the larger focus on this is that
superman could just make the world be
better right he really could like he
could just take out the united nations
or he could force them to do whatever it
is that he wants them to do like he did
an injustice right where batman like
when when literally the president
orchestrated the kidnapping of
superman's parents and then batman
confronted the president was like why
would you be so stupid right like do you
have any idea who you're messing with no
one's going to be looking for your body
on saturn right like literally superman
could just come here into the white
house kidnap you in the dead of night
kill like drag you into space where you
would die and drop your body off on
saturn and no one's going to be looking
for you there you'll just disappear you
know he could just throw you into deep
space and that would be it there's a
million ways he could take you out you
know superman could do that it'd be very
easy for him to but what superman has to
wrestle with is the difference between
making the world a better place and
helping people try to see that they can
make the world a better place and also
running into the kind of issues that you
run into along the way it'd be a very
topical film having said that it can't
focus heavily on that because if it did
it would feel like too much of a
political superman movie and the reality
is that people have to see a superman
film and feel like that superman is like
their granddad superman right the guy
who's got it all figured out the guy
who's like okay like this is what we
need to do right the one who's the one
that you can like look up to right i
mean you don't necessarily want the one
who's like i mean i'm trying to figure
it out just like you are and moping
around you know like henry cavill did
the man of steel like well i don't know
if humanity is worth saving that kind of
a thing right it's just coming to terms
with the fact that okay saving the world
won't be as easy as i thought it would
be but it can still be done now the
benefit of this is that because we are
kind of telling a superman origin story
to a degree birthright would basically
give us the ability to invoke those
elements of his origin without it being
so much on the nose in the sense that we
focus on lois lane we focus on lex
luthor how those relationships came to
be the history of lex luthor in
smallville superman's life in smallville
to a degree doesn't necessarily have to
be that on the nose the biggest thing
you have to contend with with a superman
movie is how do you make one that's
interesting because his villains aren't
really intriguing outside of like maybe
doomsday sometimes i guess and like lex
luthor and only because lex luthor can
outthink superman that's the only real
real benefit that you have there
everything else is just kind of like i
mean what like metallo right i mean i
don't know i mean nobody else there is
really intriguing in that way so i think
focusing more on the character
development of superman as opposed to
him just beating the crap out of people
consistently is an important thing now
you would see that stuff and it's a way
to kind of kind of bridge that gap right
you could quite literally do a movie
where you split the difference where you
have superman doing something to try to
make the world a better place or
whatever it is and over the course of
the film he flashes back to different
parts of his origins lex luthor lois
lane things like that so you kind of get
both but following that we go into
wonder woman now the reality here is
that the wonder woman film the way it
was originally done was not bad and i
really enjoyed it wonder woman 1984 was
not very good and it was pretty obvious
that they wanted to like warner brothers
wanted a sequel they just had no idea
what they wanted it to be so they said
just make something and send it out
there and then we'll just slap wonder
woman 1984 on it and then there we go it
was pretty obvious right it was not that
great of a movie and wasn't nearly as
good as the first one having said that
the first one was okay but it wasn't the
greatest movie that there ever was with
wonder woman i would heavily borrow from
that film the thing that i would do here
though if we really wanted to create
some crossover and we really wanted to
focus on the nature of wonder woman
herself i would do either hikatea or i
would do a league of one so a league of
one was great because it's a little too
much for a film especially because we
don't really have the justice league and
it requires the justice league for it
you know in order for it to be
significant but the idea is that there
was basically this eldritch creature
that was returning or supposed to return
it was prophesied to return and that it
would destroy the justice league and so
the league itself basically you know
when wonder woman told him everything
they were like we need to band together
and destroy this threat but the response
of wonder woman is no if you do you're
all prophesized to die and i can't let
you do that and because the response was
well i mean we're a team like we're not
going to let you go there by yourself
she beat the hell out of everybody in
the justice league knocked them all
unconscious and then went to go fight
this thing it was cool it really
showcased the fact that when it comes
down to it wonder woman's pretty legit
but i think a better story than that
would be to do the story of hikatea this
was a phenomenal story right it was
written by greg rucka one of the most
underappreciated wonder woman stories
ever done the way this played out is it
was it focused more on wonder woman and
so far as her history and her legacy as
opposed to her just beating things up
what happened here is that essentially a
woman just showed up on the doorstep of
wonder woman and when when one woman
answered the door the woman was like i
swear a vow of hikatea and wonder woman
had to accept it now the reason why is
because of the ritual that goes into
hicate that if wonder woman had declined
to accept that vow the fates would have
killed her the fates being like this
kind of trinity of magical beings that
exist out there the other part of this
is that the way hecatea works it's a
kind of honor on both sides so this
woman couldn't show up to the house of
wonder woman and say i swear valve
hikatea and then never leave the
expectation is that she would honor
wonder woman as her host she would treat
wonder woman with respect but she
wouldn't take advantage of her and when
whatever it was that required her to
take a vow of hecate had passed she
would continue on she would move on the
opposite was that wonder woman couldn't
abuse this woman she couldn't treat her
like a servant or anything like that she
had to treat her like a person being
hosted in her home with respect and
honor and so on and so forth now you end
up finding out this is one of the
coolest ways to cross over these
characters without really having like a
justice league or anything like that is
that you end up finding out this woman
had swore valve hicated a wonder woman
because she was fleeing gotham city and
the reason she was fleeing gotham is
because she was tracking down her sister
and this woman's sister had basically
taken off to gotham under the idea that
she could have like that hollywood life
when she got there she had some really
shady agents that basically had her
working some roles that weren't really
that great she ended up getting involved
in the adult film industry was kind of
forced into it when her career died off
because she wasn't as attractive as she
used to be she was forced into
prostitution and then when she wasn't
able to make as much money as she used
to the guys killed her and so this woman
basically came after those guys and then
killed those guys batman figured out
that this woman had killed those guys
and was after her so this woman takes
off to to wonder woman's place swears
the vow of hecatea because she knows
wonder woman will protect her from
batman and that's what happens batman
shows up on the doorstep of wonder woman
and is like give me the girl and wonder
woman's like no and batman's response is
then i'll take her and wonder woman
beats his ass and throws him out of the
apartment it's like if you ever come
back here again i'm gonna kill you and
that's basically it because literally if
wonder woman had handed this woman over
to to batman the fates would have killed
wonder woman so it's a really really
cool thing because what it does is it
highlights and shows this idea that
wonder woman's
her presence in the comic book landscape
is a lot more than just like the female
version of superman who can fight really
well there's plenty of time for that in
future movies what we need to do here is
break down these characters give people
a good depiction of the characters and
the histories that go with it because it
takes things away from her just beating
up some villain like you know cheetah
who nobody wants to see anymore and
focuses more on her being a woman in the
superhero landscape and other women
coming to her for aid but then also
reconciling you know what she does when
she's lied to because she was duped
initially by this woman this woman like
she told her told one woman to lie for
why she was you know swearing the vow of
hecate wonder woman found out later but
it's just one of those cool things that
goes on between the two right it's a
really really good way to show some
strong female representation in uh in
the comic book movie landscape in a way
that to be quite frank with you guys the
marvel cinematic universe has failed to
do with like one division or captain
marvel or any of that stuff right so
again more of a character focused story
now following that there's a couple
different options here we can do cyborg
whatever i mean cyborg has in my mind
he's always kind of sucked i've never
been interested in cyborg more often
than not in the comics he's just the
security guard for the justice league
he's useful sometimes but not really all
that important we could go into aquaman
if we do honestly i wouldn't bring back
jason mamoa he was not a bad aquaman but
he felt less like a king and more like
conan the barbarian who had become
aquaman right he was not terrible in
that role jason momoa is a phenomenal
actor honestly if i had it my way if i
were jason momoa i would bail on the dc
cinematic universe i'd try to get the
role of hyperion in dc and i'm sorry in
the marvel cinematic universe like i
would try for that role because i think
jason momoa would be a phenomenal
hyperion in the mcu god he would be
amazing but only if they keep him long
term right if he's like marcus milton of
earth one three zero three four right
like an eternal from an alternate
reality that's that's the the hyperion
that i would want and i think jason
momoa would be phenomenal for that role
having said that i don't really know who
i would pick to play aquaman but i would
make the film less fast and the furious
and more
a king trying to find his place in the
world type thing you know what i mean
like i wouldn't really say like a king
arthur type story but something akin to
that because the biggest issue that i
had with aquaman is it felt like a very
fast and the furious type movie which
makes sense right it was directed by
james wants so i mean guy does fast in
the furious films but i don't think
that's what that movie needed to be it
didn't need to be one of those things
where like him and amber heard are
walking out of the ocean and you almost
expect dom to come riding alongside him
and they look at dom and dom looks at
them and it's like we're family like you
know i didn't want that you know like
that's that's what that movie would have
felt like and that's not what aquaman is
supposed to be in a lot of ways aquaman
needs to be a film that is really kind
of a representation of how we would see
him like a guy walking around with a
chip on his shoulder like okay so like
you're superman of the ocean and you
talk to fish like that kind of a thing
right like it needs to be that where he
kind of has that little bit of a chip on
his shoulder but he's also trying to
prove himself and then dealing with the
surface world in the ocean world a man
split between two worlds things along
those lines so again i felt like the
aquaman movie lacked that i think that's
a way to pick that up again i'm not too
focused on cyborg and aquaman i mean
they're there cool yeah whatever they do
some stuff honestly the big thing here
would probably be green lantern now how
you would handle green lantern i don't
entirely know this guy would kind of
round out what we would call the the
core justice league the only way to
really do this is you would have to know
what the greater plan was when it came
to the green lantern are we going in the
direction of like you know brightest day
and blackest night or blackest night and
brightest day are we going in the
direction of like the sinestro corps war
i think that green lantern is one of
those characters where he can be a part
of the traditional justice league and he
shows up occasionally but his movies
need to be almost kind of isolated right
just the rare example here where they're
out there by themselves just kind of
doing their own thing separated from
everything else that's what i would do
with him right that way you could do
green lantern and you could do things
like sinestro core war and no one's
really going to be asking the question
well where's the justice league in all
of this right because this is a much
bigger thing than the justice league
itself right you could do things like
blackest night and brightest day and
then potentially bring back the justice
league the bigger problem here is that
when it came to blackest night and
brightest day for those of you guys who
don't know blackest night was a story
that had long since been alluded to ever
since the the original green lantern
rebirth story by jeff johns and the
whole purpose of blackest day and uh
blackest night and brightest day was
basically for blackest night to have the
black lanterns resurrect every single
superhero that had died as like a zombie
and then brightest day gave white
lantern rings or used the white lantern
rings to quote unquote cure those who
were black lanterns and return them to
life but the reality here is on a
publishing side it was just a way for dc
to bring back all the characters who had
died that they wanted to keep and the
ones they didn't want to keep they would
all go back to being dead because they
were too far corrupted or the white
lantern rings couldn't fix them or
something along those lines so again you
know that's that's more of a very a very
particular story that served a very
particular purpose so i don't know if we
would really do that in movie form the
reality here is in my mind if we're
talking about something you know
comparable to the first 10-year
conclusion in the mcu right in an
infinity war in avengers in-game type
thing i would do crisis on infinite
earth and the way in which i would do
this is that while these would be movies
that we would focus on i would build up
alternate realities in different ways
what i would do here is i would do a
combination of tv shows and post credits
scenes that in effect what i would have
in the post credit scenes of these
various movies is quite literally
darkseid as the big bad but steppenwolf
executing his plan kind of similar to
what zack snyder did but not in the
crappy way that he did what i would do
here is i would do things like in a
post-credits scene for like superman or
batman or something like that it would
be earth 2 and it would be an alternate
universe that story in dc comics when
steppenwolf showed up to earth 2 in that
alternate reality at the behest of
darkseid at the direction of darkseid
and then basically killed that
universe's batman superman in wonderland
well technically superman was turned
into a parademon but basically like
batman sacrificed his life he died
wonder woman was killed and superman was
just turned into one of the parademons
of dark side and that was it but
basically the superheroes there died the
difference is that instead of giving us
like a new landscape of superheroes like
you had in the earth 2 series they would
just like destroy that world or
something like that but what that would
be designed to illustrate is like dark
sides on the hunt for a particular thing
either that or he's just looking to
expand his his roster or his forces or
just doing what darkseid does we don't
necessarily know but on the other side
of the equation where the post-credit
scenes of those movies are showing what
darkseid's doing behind the scenes
because we don't need a whole series
dedicated to that on the tv side i would
tell stories of alternate realities it
would just be one-shot episodes right
like you literally get earth prime the
one shot origin of super boy prawn you
get uh you know maybe some alternate
universe where it's like the one shot
origin of alan scott the green lantern
of that alternate reality and what it
would do because it's one episode and
it's self-contained it's easy enough for
the average person to digest but it
creates enough curiosity that that
average person wants to know more and so
you could literally have everybody else
just explaining it to them right like me
or anybody out there just filling in the
gaps that's literally what we do so it's
like hey you saw the alan scott tv show
like are you curious about alan scott
okay here's a little more about that
character he's basically the original
green lantern that dc published long
before hal jordan or jon stewart or guy
gardner or anything like that just
different things along those lines right
or maybe some alternate reality where
you get a one-shot origin of jay garrick
the original flash from dc comics that
came before barry allen just things
along those lines right but the purpose
behind these episodes would basically be
to build up these different groups or
characters that will go into the main
crisis on infinite earth story itself so
whether crisis is simply just a name
that we borrow but deals more with dark
side traveling the multiverse and just
wiping out whole worlds or something
along those lines kind of replacing what
would traditionally be the anti-monitor
or we take the real anti-monitor himself
which i think is a little too convoluted
for the average tv show and movie fan we
basically have all these different
characters from alternate realities all
teaming up in the official crisis on
infinidur's film and literally all you
have to do is watch the show to
understand what's going on there i know
some people might say well most people
aren't going to do that i think they
would i think that wanda vision and loki
and all those shows actually show that
people would i think it demonstrates
that people would if word of mouth is
out there and it's like this is really
cool like you got like this is a really
cohesive universe it's really more
cohesive than what the marvel cinematic
universe is doing i think people would
buy into it and i think they would
really really like it so having said
that i know people are going to ask like
what about the flash honestly i haven't
really figured out how i would handle
the flash i don't know if i would do
barry allen with grant gustin or i would
do like wally west or something along
those lines i haven't quite figured that
out and i'm kind of leaning towards the
idea of having the flash just be its own
maybe anthology series or something like
that kind of a series of movies on its
own that's tied in but not necessarily i
don't know let me know what you guys
think again none of this is like a
definitive plan i'm creating i'm not
really saying like this is what the dc
cinematic universe needs to do i just
think it's a cool idea i think it's a
cool way to basically rework their
landscape and if they really want to
stay hot on the heels or even surpass
the mcu i think this is a great way to
do it with that being said we're going
to bring this to an end thank you guys
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace